viele erleben digitale unterricht so
dass der lehrer sich meldet per e-mail
und in e mail rein schreibt welche
seiten gelesen werden sollen
wenn ich im moment kultusminister
bildungsministerin wäre wär mir das
ehrlich gesagt ein hinein ländern gibt
es lernen management systeme in allen
ländern gibt es jetzt auch
videokonferenzen die finden mehr oder
weniger regelmäßig statt natürlich hätte
ich mir gewünscht dass wir im vorfeld
deswegen haben wir den digital packt
aufgelegt dass wir vorankommen digitaler
bildung war ganz cool ist ihnen so was
peinlich wenn wenn man es als lehrer
nicht schafft mehr zu machen als eine e
mail zu schreiben in der dann drinsteht
was die schüler lesen sollen wichtig ist
dass wir denen die noch nicht so gut
damit umgehen können die vielleicht auch
nur mit diesen lern management system
noch nicht optimal umgehen können dass
wir denen unterstützung geben ich glaube
nicht dass es hilft wenn wir sagen du
kannst es nicht dass es nicht gut
sondern wichtig ist das was wie was
hilft dir dass du es besser machen
kannst das ist die richtige frage aber
würde das nicht gewaltigen druck machen
wenn sie sagen würden ich schreibe euch
standards da rein und damit seid ihr
gezwungen das umzusetzen in den nächsten
monaten zum einen haben wir an der
umsetzung ja im grunde auch keine
handlungsmöglichkeit keine
eingriffsmöglichkeiten
und ich glaube auch dass es wichtig ist
dass wir jetzt nicht einfach nur druck
machen sondern dass wir immer wieder
auch unterstützung geben und sagen so wo
können wir dennoch helfen es muss auch
eine positive aufbruchstimmung in den
schulen entstehen das jetzt weiter zu
entwickeln
viele fragen sind nur vor ort zu lösen
und das können kann man dann in einer
gemeinschaft zwischen eltern schülern
und lehrkräften und auch immer der
kommune zusammen am besten und nicht von
hier über toleranz haben ganz viele
eltern nicht mehr und toleranz bedeutet
halt oft ist passiert an vielen stellen
nicht hättest die möglichkeit gegeben
dass sie sich einfach hinstellen und
sagen jaja ich weiss ich kenne natürlich
die länderzuständigkeit aber wir haben
besondere krisenzeiten
ich bin jetzt dafür verantwortlich ich
kümmere mich da das haben wir gemacht
dass wir gesagt haben wo können wir die
länder noch unterstützen diese drei
zusatzprogramme beim digital park
endgeräte für lehrer endgeräte für die
schüler und auch administratoren
strukturen aufzubauen das ist genau das
wo wir gesagt haben da wollen wir
unterstützen weil die ländern gesagt
haben an den punkten hakt es noch aber
es bleibt dabei wir warnt vor der krise
sehr
unterschiedlich aufgestellt und neun
monate in einer krise zu managen
das ist natürlich eine herausforderung
an sich überhaupt schon und ich verstehe
jeden der sagt mein gott was ist das
jetzt alles das läuft alles nicht
wirklich gut aber es hilft nichts wir
müssen durch diese krise gemeinsam durch